si bien puede haber controversias la
comisión de la verdad esclarecer qué
ocurrió
esclarece y él mencionó habrán cosas en
las cuales seguramente haya que seguir
indagando porque no se cuenta con un
relato claro pero el sentido de hacer
esta tarea es esclarecer y decir esto
realmente fue que fue lo que ocurrió
vale la pena tener en cuenta que también
se trata de una de una verdad histórica
no la verdad jurídica y esta verdad
histórica también digamos de alguna
manera se va construyendo como un
símbolo en el que se le asigna
responsabilidades a los actores en la
comisión de delitos de violaciones a
derechos humanos y les permite a partir
de hacerlos partícipes de reconocerlo y
en ese sentido de aportar la
reconciliación no solamente el relato
los hizo partícipes de contar el relato
y creo que hay también lo mencionó se
habló con ex presidentes con los que
están vivos se habló con empresarios se
habló con actores armados es decir
bueno con miembros que estuvieron que
hicieron parte de los actores armados
con las farc ellos al contar el relato
al contar la verdad lo hacen también
para
aportar a la reconciliación que éste sea
un gesto que no solamente está escrito
no es sólo papel es un gesto que además
quiero resaltar el énfasis que puso
gustavo petro que no es una verdad para
que continúen las venganzas que no sea
revanchista
que permita generar el diálogo y cierre
conflictos